[Musique]
l'art contemporain à l'honneur le temps
d'un weekend les 7 et 8 octobre dernier
le marché international d'art
contemporain arm Manet ouvrait ses
portes pour une 20e édition organisée
par le lance club Montini un des
intérêts de cette manifestation c'est
bien sûr de découvrir beaucoup
d'œuvre dans des techniques très
différentes mais surtout c'est de venir
découvrir des artistes et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de discuter avec les
artistes ils ont beaucoup de plaisir à
échanger sur leur techniques sur leur
univers artistique peintre sculpteurs
mais aussi photographe une quarantaine
d'artistes étent sélectionnés pour
l'occasion comme cet ancien architecte
venu exposer ses croquis pour la 3è
année je travaille avec une technique
très simple et rapide c'est-à-dire
l'encre exclusivement et l'aquarelle de
techniques qui permettent d'avoir une
spontanéité parfaite sans correction
et un premier jet donc je provoque
l'imaginaire je propose et le visiteur
pénètre dans le dessin je suis toujours
surpris j'ai un accueil merveilleux j'ai
les gens qui rêvent alors ceux c'est il
pénètrent avec moi dans dans ma bulle
Paris réussi pour lui récompensé par le
Prix du public pour la seconde année
consécutive parfait merci beaucoup
rendez-vous incontournable pour les
amateurs d'art de la région j'adore
l'art jeis toujours impression parce que
les gens arrivent à réaliser de leur
main pour ces 20 ans la manifestation a
connu un vif succès avec près de 1500
personnes présentes sur place